oh this is a terrible idea I'm gonna see
if I can cook a steak using nothing but
the heat from inside a compost pile
compost piles actually get really hot
because of microorganisms within the
tile that breaks down the organic
material releasing heat to avoid killing
important bacteria a compost pile should
get up to no more than 160 degrees fair
enough
these high temperatures can be reached
if the pile is big enough and has the
right balance of carbons and nitrogen's
for their microorganisms so basically
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna wrap up a
steak and some other foods dig into a
compost pile put them in there and leave
them there for a full day all right so
we got our sweet potatoes eggs chocolate
cake and most importantly we have some
steak so let's throw these into the
holes cover them up and see if it cooks
it was a bad idea to do this in Texas it
is really hot so now we got everything
placed on the piles we cover them up
with dirt and then leave them sitting
for a day and see if the cut okay so
it's been a day so let's go dig it up
and see if this worked I think my hands
are too big for the gloves here we go
okay let's start with the eggs and see
if we got a nice hard-boiled egg in
there
that's hot let's take a look okay it
looks like they've cracked and have not
cooked off to a pretty bad start not
very promising so let's move on the smut
grows all right oh here this feels
pretty soft all right let's see if it
cooked cake did not cook either
might have been too much batter this
might be a failure let's move on
you got the potatoes okay well they feel
pretty soft
I think I'll definitely give these a try
time for the ultimate test the steak
come on where are ya oh this one's
really hot fingers crossed
ah all right so you can see it's got
some nice brown color to it got the
juices flowing out I can't wait to try
this bad boy
[Laughter]
I'm gonna start off with the sweet
potatoes and see how those turned out
yeah that's not bad it's got a nice
crunch to it feels like it's been cooked
so the eggs did not work they got
smashed at some point so I don't think I
will be trying these today no thanks all
right buddy
this guy just walked over here he must
have smelled the delicious aroma of my
home-cooked meal not for you sorry buddy
the cake didn't really cook it got
thicker but it's pretty liquidy
throughout just looks like poop all
right let's try the steak this is the
main course you got a nice tender juicy
steak it's nice and browned on the
outside got a little color on the inside
but it's still fully cooked oh man yeah
that's good it's weirdly perfectly
cooked it's got a nice smooth texture I
would give this steak a 9 out of 10 when
it's not covered with flies I'd say this
was a success we need another piece I'm
gonna finish this whole steak there's my
dinner right there
[Music]